if you play dying light one you may
already know that developer techland
loves a good easter egg as that game was
full of them because of this fans have
been eager to know what type of secrets
awaited them in dying light too well now
that the game is officially out and
players have taken to the streets of
vilador with their detective hats on i'm
happy to report that techland did not
disappoint in this video we're going
over a few of the easter eggs sprinkled
throughout the city from video game
references to pop culture references
we've got a list of 20 you may have
missed for more dying light 2 videos
make sure you're subscribed to gamespot
in the opening moments of dying light 2
while exploring the location of the end
of the world party you can find a record
player with a vinyl of zambi's who do
you voodoo from dead island
who do you voo do hmm
sounds familiar
[Music]
once you're all done exploring the house
you'll sit down to enjoy a drink with an
old friend and during this cutscene
dying light protagonist kyle crane is
briefly referenced
i wish crane could have seen this who
doesn't matter
and this isn't the only time crane is
referenced later in the game you'll meet
another character the liquidator that
also mentions him you can do amazing
stuff
almost like kyle crane
kyle crane
a friend of mine mentioned that name
once who is he
you mean
who was he
kyle was a hero
he was going to save her on and that
moment with the liquidator has two
easter eggs for the price of one because
when he's done talking he leaves you a
cyber hands
2177 weapon blueprint you don't want to
miss these they're so cool
but wait there's more references to kyle
crane one of which is the graffiti on
this crane honoring his existence and
basically calling him the best another
one is a room that features a shrine to
crane there is even a tape you can sit
down and listen to of crane talking to
other characters
great job
thanks i hope it's enough
you had any contact with jade
god
damn it [ __ ]
no
i know
like i hope this [ __ ] was worth it
crane
jade is that you crane i heard what you
did i see
what you did
you know how to make a statement your
reward for sitting down and listening to
this tape will come in the form of new
sneakers for aiding called it's me
marian the description of the item says
wow i can do triple jumps
so after leaving that house in the intro
of the game and starting your trek
towards vilador you might be tempted to
gaze at the beautiful scenery and the
sunset that accompanies it at one spot
if you look closely you can catch a
glimpse of the tree from the dead island
logo
the references to older tech land games
don't stop there because once you get to
the bazaar in vilador you'll find
missing slash wanted person posters for
dying light 1 characters
dying light 2 also makes references to
other video games as well in the second
half of the story you'll encounter a
character named leon who is looking for
another named chris these are in honor
of the classic horror franchise resident
evil this is where my story ends bro
hey man don't talk like that
is there any more survivors
aren't you the blind optimist
chris
he punched through and went that way
the black guy
i think it was his doing once you find
chris later on in the quest and pick up
his dog tags you'll discover that it
reads chris redfield just in case she
needed more proof
so i know this fungus exists in real
life but its position on this infected
person seems like a small nod to the
last of us series you can also find this
growing on tree stumps throughout
vilador so this is the closest to being
a reference in my opinion
once you beat the game you can return to
the vnc tower where hidden beneath is a
secret doom-like level waiting for you
unfortunately you'll have to find all of
the demonic ducks in order to get this
going
[Music]
but dying light 2 also includes
non-video game references too such as
this note from dwight schrute a popular
character from the american version of
the office
once you make it to the central loop
you'll find big time square like
billboards one of which is for a musical
called the walking dead a clear
reference to another zombie-filled
property the walking dead another pop
culture reference comes in the form of a
rideable back to the future like
hoverboard because who in their right
mind doesn't love back to the future and
if it's you please please don't let me
know
another writable secret is this flying
broomstick and honestly this might be a
couple references in one because it's
called the baba yaga parkour challenge
john wick is called baba yaga the
description mentions fast and furious
and then goes on to talk about
dish quid which seems like the game
quidditch from harry potter just
backwards
[Music]
dying light 2 also features a master
sword in various spots on the map but it
doesn't seem like it's usable just the
kids toy and set dressing
damn knuckleheads
always eager to punish
something that is usable however is this
boomerang like frying pan that you can
receive as a gift from a space chicken
what the hell
a talking henko
possibly the most complicated of the
easter eggs to unlock is the tecline
developer room unfortunately for me i
encountered a bug each time i tried to
reach it but if you're luckier than me
and can get into the dev room there's an
awesome special ability that i think is
the coolest of the easter eggs a finger
gun
another cool item in the dev room is a
weapon charm that you can use to achieve
unlimited weapon repairs you'll never
have to say goodbye to your favorite
weapon ever again so are you playing
dying light 2 yet what secrets have you
found scattered throughout the world let
us know in the comments below
[Music]
you